(moody music)
This is Rich Chigga.
He's a Chinese rapper by way of Indonesia,
and he's very popular on the internet.
This is Joji.
He's a Japanese-Australian singer
and he's also very
popular on the internet.
Plus, Joji invented the Harlem Shake meme.
Let me say that again.
This guy, Joji, in the blood bathtub,
invented the Harlem Shake meme.
But we'll come back to that.
So, Rich and Joji are
both signed to 88rising,
an entertainment company hoping to build
a lasting global brand that will outlive
singular moments of virality.
They primarily create content
combining Asian culture and hip-hop,
a formula that apparently pleases
the internet gods greatly.
They've only been around for 18 months,
but they're already putting
up major label numbers.
I think that we have an unprecedented
collective of talent.
A group of predominantly Asian artists,
you know, really like
making waves globally,
which from an independent
point of view as well.
88's founder, Sean Miyashiro,
cut his teeth launching
Vice's electronic music channel, Thump.
But quickly, Sean became
interested in life
beyond dance music.
I knew that, after launching
a whole content platform,
that I have kind of the ability
and the know-how to do it again,
but for what was the question.
So Sean moved to the Bronx to start over
and figure it out.
He couldn't afford an office space,
so he worked out of his car
at the top of a grimy parking garage.
Everything kinda started here.
If you look around,
this is my environment,
this is my serenity, really.
88rising was built here.
Built on the grounds
of LA Fitness residence
in a parking garage.
I was living in the
Bronx and I'm just like,
damn, where the hell do I go?
So I just come up here
and I like, you know,
I just kind of figure
things out every single day,
being like, okay, what
the hell is this thing?
(laughs)
Coming here was kind of like
my own kind of private office basically.
Like, to be honest, I would
even go to the bathroom here.
I would take pisses here,
you know what I mean?
Like, you know, it's just too
far to go back down there.
When I need wi-fi, I'd
spend a good part of the day
at Dunkin Donuts.
Hi, how are you?
Can I get a chicken snack wrap?
Before 88rising officially launched,
Sean caught a surprise break
in the form of a Twitter friendship
with a funny 16-year-old kid
from Indonesia named Brian,
who taught himself English by watching
Rubik's Cube tutorial videos on YouTube.
Seriously, that's true.
I thought his Twitter was genius,
from the future, just crazy.
And like, just the shit
that he was saying,
like the memes he was making.
But I didn't know that he
rapped or anything like that.
I really didn't, and he
came up with Dat $tick
like two weeks later.
♪ 12 in the morning, pop
shells for a living ♪
♪ And berry gon' smell
blood trail every minute ♪
Dat $tick was Brian's first ever attempt
at making a rap song, and
it immediately went viral.
Everything was great about it,
but the one thing that I noticed
is the song was hard as hell.
Just like everything about it, man.
Just like, it was menacing, bro.
Soon after the video dropped,
Brian signed with 88rising.
I'll FaceTime with Rich.
Sorry for calling you Rich
Chigga on my phone, Rich.
He gets, I mean Brian, he
gets like super pissed off
that he's saved in my
phone as Rich Chigga.
He's like, "Dude am I not a human to you?"
What's good, bro?
What's good, broda?
How you doing?
Doing great, I did the sound check.
How was it?
It was tight.
♪ Holdin' steel glocks ♪
♪ But you been a bitch,
suck a thick cock ♪
So, Brian could definitely rap,
but some viewers
understandably took offense
at a Chinese kid satirizing rap cliches
and calling himself "Rich Chigga."
But if a group of well-known
rappers saw the video
and genuinely liked it,
that could at least help validate Brian
as a legit hip-hop artist.
Plus, it could be really funny.
It was just kind of an idea that kind of
I just had on the spot.
Everything that rappers
say is better and funnier
and smarter, and wittier.
You know, it's just more entertaining.
We just edit it as tight
as possible, put it up,
and it really worked.
(shouting)
Yo, this nigga got a
pouch on, a Reebok pouch.
This is the hardest nigga of all time.
He said when you come
for a chigga like me.
That was dope.
This is lit and I think
people will take is as a...
People will take is as a joke at first,
but it's like,
if he ran with that and kept
doing more videos like that,
shit's lit.
You know, I had never
been to America before
and all of a sudden it's like I see like
all the rappers that I listen
to reacting to my stuff
and I was like, 'What?
How did this happen?'
The reaction video also went viral
and even led to a remix of Dat $tick
featuring Wu-Tang's Ghostface.
I'll get on that track.
You know what I'm saying, yeah.
Really, on the remix?
Yeah, yeah, oh, you know him?
And, yeah, the remix went viral too.
Brian has since acknowledged
the misstep in his name
and claims he made changes,
but for the time being,
he's still Rich Chigga to his fans,
an ever-growing global audience
hungry for more releases
from emerging talents
from around the world.
I didn't know that it was gonna
be this impactful and
this important to people
and I'm very thankful
and blessed that it has,
and every day now that I wake up
it's like, you know, just
a new mission every day.
A major part of that mission
involves Joji.
Remember the bloody bath guy?
He's a former YouTube personality
in the middle of a career transition.
The sound of this song, Will He,
it's like a trap song that
you can slow dance to.
Awkward prom shit.
You know what I mean?
I used to do crazy,
episodic internet videos.
It was going well and one day
it was me and a few
friends just in a room.
We were casually chilling
and then someone plays the song
and it's brand new at the time.
I happened to have a lot
of costumes laying around,
so I told the other guys,
I was like, get in these costumes
and let's just dance to it.
Like who cares?
We were like, okay, let's
just go crazy at the drop.
So that video goes up,
I go to sleep
and the next morning
everyone was doing it.
Like next morning.
("Harlem Shake")
That taught me a lot about the internet.
How people wanna just
be a part of something.
And from that point on
something changed
and I was a little better at understanding
demographics and people
and what they want to see
and what they want to hear.
I was friends with a couple other artists
who were affiliated with 88
and then I also started to realize that 88
is the bridge between Western
and Asian entertainment
and I really wanted to be a part of that.
Joji just released the In Tongues EP,
his first project as a serious artist.
Joji's In Tongues record
came out a couple weeks ago.
It's number two in the
world on the R&B chart,
which is crazy for independent release
and he's like a brand new artist.
And the success is even more impressive
knowing he went from
creating something like this
It's just Taco Bell,
what could possibly go wrong?
(screams)
To creating something like this.
The newest music video
for his song Demons.
♪ The demons told me everything ♪
♪ They whisper in the night ♪
♪ This is not a threat, I promise ♪
Tonight Rich Chigga has a show
in New York City.
Tickets sold out in an hour.
I came here, I'm first on line,
I came here at one.
I was the third person in line.
So, why'd you get here so early?
Cause I wanna see Rich Chigga.
(yelling)
I wanna touch him.
(laughter)
What do you guys think of Joji?
He's hot, bro.
Oh my God.
That's my dad, son.
You guys copped the new EP?
Yeah.
I woke up at six in the morning
just to cop that shit
and then I listened to it
and that shit started made me cry, fam.
This is actually kind of exciting.
Every time...
This never gets old, like,
you live online in social media,
but there's nothing like this.
Being with the people.
(cheering)
Ten, nine,
Eight, seven, six, five,
four, three, two, one.
(screaming)
♪ Back on my bullshit,
man you can't believe it ♪
♪ Who the fuck just said I should quit ♪
More often that not
viral success happens by accident.
And then after an appearance on Ellen
or Jimmy Kimmel
the creator's star power fizzles out.
But 88rising has figured out
how to turn potential gimmicks into brands
with an actual following
that keeps coming back for the next thing.
Oh, shit.
So keep an eye out for 88's next move.
More than likely,
it won't be covered on network television
or terrestrial radio.
Although, as they've already proven,
nowadays that really doesn't matter.